on est sur le stand de lg dans le cadre
de l'ifa lors il ya plein de choses
hyper intéressante
lg je passe au dessus quand on a déjà
parlé dans le cadre du cs avec des
écrans oled qui se met dans tous les
autres cas ça c'est incroyable
et là vous avez les écrans qui rendent
qui s'entend pas c'est plutôt dingue on
est avec les gérone de lg va jérôme ça
va très bien merci bonjour bonjour on
parle de ça aujourd'hui alors aux oscars
un petit tour du stand tu montes tu
m'expliques un peu où en est l g
aujourd'hui exactement il ya des techno
qui sont complètement faux le faire
l'objectif c'est de vous accompagner
vous montrer tout ce qui est capable de
faire aujourd'hui lg et plus
particulièrement dans l'affichage est ce
que vous avez que les gens n'écoutent
pas mauvais là dessus
grâce à l'oled ce grâce à l'oled on perd
mais on peut faire autre idée télé qui
sont incomparables et notamment sa qui
est juste derrière vous pourriez
derrière c'est un écran roulable lg une
première mondiale un projet de science
fiction vraiment qu'on avait présentée
au cs est là aujourd'hui on est capable
de vous le montrez vous en parler un peu
plus parce que les eaux de l'oled c'est
aussi de là oui car on est aussi présent
sur l'a8 cachés érigés en oled est aussi
un lcd led et deux solutions d'affichage
on a vraiment une gamme complète les
deux sur la vie quand les deux sur la
burqa et après on fera un petit update
sur des des produits sympathique
notamment des moniteurs gaming elle
jettera guerre avec une nouveauté qu'on
présente cette année est celle phare des
projecteur laser 4k et aussi tout ce qui
concerne la maison connectée la maison
de demain la maison du futur où tous les
appareils peuvent parler les uns avec
les autres et interagir vous permettre
de mûrir votre méthode est la venue chez
lg
[Musique]
quand une espèce de d'enceinte et en
fait c'est ta télé bah oui c'est la télé
vous la voyez pas pour l'instant mais
vous allez voir dans quelques secondes
il ya un écran qui va sortir qui va se
dérouler de sa barre de son ouais
allemand il arrive
le voilà et c'est l'écran enroulable
belge et lg signature oled rr comme
relève l air comme révolutionnaire parce
qu'on est sur un produit révolutionnaire
ici c'est incroyable ça change la donne
pour votre salon généralement quand vous
déménagez et quand vous êtes dans votre
nouvel appartement dans le salon la
première question que vous posez c'est
est-ce que je vais mettre ma télé
monique laveau forcément contre un mur
dans un cas maintenant ici quand vous
regardez pas la télé l'écran n'existe
pas il disparaît dans ce système de ce
monde pouvait faire comme ils sont
maîtres la télé en séparation de deux
espaces de vie dans votre salon entre la
salle à manger à table la salle à manger
et les canapés par exemple
pouvait reprendre possession de vos murs
on met des étages et à mettre de la
bibliothèque donc
envisagez votre architecture de maison
d'une manière complètement différente et
ça c'est grâce à nous laisse ça c'est un
produit qui aujourd'hui tu vas pas trop
dans tous les foyers
ça progresse et coûteux donc c'est un
projet d'innovation clairement c'est
même un produit de luxe ont cotisé
encore aujourd'hui il sera commercialisé
en france en juin 2020 donc l'année
prochaine à des flics je peux pas encore
communiqué mais je peux vous dire que
c'est clairement un produit de luxe
on change la donne sur le marché de la
télé et l'innovation 1 sélection savoir
pouvoir retrouver dans quelques années
dans tous les foyers démocratiser à
terme oui ça va se démocratiser
aujourd'hui c'est le début d'une
nouvelle histoire avec ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas eu un
produit qui change la donne sur la télé
depuis qu'on était passé à l'écran plat
aujourd'hui le fait de rendre sa télé
flexible et de la faire disparaître
on ouvre une nouvelle page on démarre
une nouvelle histoire dans le monde de
la télé pour petit à petit état par état
puis ça va se développer là on n'est pas
bon
mika rôle est qui
exactement on démarre la vue qu'a aussi
maintenant chez lg est entré sur notre
technologie
militaire c'est-à-dire l'oled
téléviseurs lg signature oled lui car
c'est un écran de 81 8 pouces 81 10
pouces wi cas c'est comme si vous aviez
quatre téléviseurs 2,44 pouces quatre
canetons tabou on pas perdre en
résolution d'image sur votre téléviseur
des écrans toujours plus
mais il faut remplir avec les
différentes
puis cassé 33 millions de pixels
il sera commercialisé en france moment à
prochain en moindre mois d'octobre le
prix de ce téléviseur
je sais ça va être cher mélo 28 92 a un
coût et en l'occurrence et sa princesse
30 millions exact ok c'est pas pour tout
le monde mais en tout cas ça arrive mais
ça arriver il faut commencer l'histoire
de la vie car la burqa c'est pas que
l'oled on va aussi venir juste après
c'est aussi en avant la noce elle
la technologie lcd led classiques là il
est à toi d'être aux éclairages
voilà les téléviseurs nanosail week à 75
sm 99 donc là on est sur une dalle d'une
largeur de 75 pouces d'accord qui
sortiront aussi au mois d'octobre donc
le mois prochain en france à un prix un
peu plus accessible qui sortiront creed
4989 euros c'est beaucoup plus axé c'est
un tout sur plusieurs stations mais
c'est du led lcd mais nos technologies
pour tout s'appelle nadeau sec
avec des noirs pour m traits parfaits
des couleurs dit miser de particules
fines
tolérant club des angles de vision très
bon ça y est vous pouvez regarder la
télé deux faces et de côté sans avoir de
la déperdition sur la couleur est aussi
[Musique]
un cadre est très fin pour optimiser la
surface de l'écran sur le téléviseur
mais sur une vraie partie audio on est
sur la partie audio chez lg chez lg
notre gamme audio s'appelle lgx boom
notamment sur la partie enceintes audio
portables netbooks gogo pour la
portabilité
on a trois anciens pk3 pk5 ep classe est
de plus en plus grosses qui ont été
définis et construite en partenariat
avec meridian qui est une marque
pionnière dans le son haute résolution
en angleterre qui nous permet d'avoir
des produits très bons notamment dans
les bases dans les aigus il existe
depuis depuis l'an dernier on a aussi
envoyé des enceintes un peu plus grande
qu'on appelle des one gaudy il ya
notamment des grosses comme ça qu'ils
ont des fonctionnalités de faire la fête
chez soi partie dj karaoké lumière
mixage pour avoir des défaites toujours
un peu plus pointu et plus poussées
lâché fin de soirée qui veut sa lumière
et en cette fin de soirée
je prévois et on envoie fort vélo on va
faire nos barres de son pour mettre avec
avec vos télés les principales
spécificités pour nous cette année c'est
que dorénavant sionneau barre de son
nouvel assistant est embarqué
directement dans la barre de son procès
donc pour les gens qui n'ont pas une
télé connectée avec google assistants
dont ils ont acheté avant 2018
vous pouvez vous connecter à google via
la barre de son sens la voir dans la
télé ou dans une enceinte équipe est
très intéressant pour certaines règles
ceriani en plus par exemple notamment
pour une enceinte comme celle là l'asm
ne vous êtes pas forcément obligé de
poser votre enceinte sur une étagère
vous pouvez la mettre au mur et la fixer
la poser à la verticale lance anne va
reconnaître la position dans laquelle
vous l'avez mise et va adapter la
diffusion du son dans en termes de
spatialisation soit entre l'horizontale
et à la verticale
donc là on est sur la partie maudite
avons une grosse nouveauté va-t-on
exactement il ya une grosse nouveauté
arrivera chez nous cette année où quand
on n'a pas parlé jusqu'à maintenant ça
va
jamais été montrées on a des nouveaux
moniteurs hemming de notre gamme lg
d'ultra gear ça s'appelle comme ça chez
nous les moniteurs gaming
chez nous chez lg historiquement nos
écrans sont faits en dalles ip sip ça
veut dire des très belles couleurs une
pureté des couleurs mais jusqu'à
maintenant on avait un temps de réponse
sur le gaming qui était un tout petit
peu plus lent entre 2 et 4 millisecondes
et hanches et que c'est l'effet rue
deming le temps de réponse 1
milliseconde c'est vraiment la cote est
utile
on a optimisé avec le nano ip est
maintenant on arrive à faire ces écrans
avec un temps de réponse de
mini secondes donc on n'est plus obligé
d'avoir un écran terne qui s'appelle un
écran avec une dalle tn
mais grâce à nani ps maintenant on a les
crocs ultime côté des couleurs temps de
réponse utilisé à 1 milliseconde
les férus de béninois est vraiment très
content notamment tous ceux qui joue aux
fps et aux jeux de course parce que le
taux de rafraîchissement en arrive à
144,6 milan ac sur sage et pour l'un
c'est on est très fier d'arriver à faire
un projecteur laser 4k
qu'ils s'appellent ainsi les villes sa
spécificité c'est très simple c'est
qu'il a très content rockhal c'est à
dire que vous ne mettez devant votre mur
à projeter une image une diagonale
immense en étant justement à quelques
centimètres de plus
positionné à 10 centimètres du mur pour
faire une image une diagonale de 120
pouces
un pouce et commence si vous le
rapprocher à 5 centimètres du mur vous
garder quand même une image d'une
diagonale de 90 pouces n'est pas
beaucoup télé aujourd'hui ça marche et
qui ont une diagonale de 92 une très
bonne alternative
mais ça vous aussi ça vous empêche de
poser la question de vous dire je vais
mettre le projecteur suspendus aux murs
au plafond ou est-ce que je vais le
mettre non contre le mur devant votre
mur avec une
votre réponse ça comme un dessin de les
gens c'est un très bel objet il sort en
france au mois de novembre cette année
et sera commercialisé au prix de 5000
999 euros
parce que c'est la 4k c'est du laser et
c'est la trique pour son calme quand on
est sur un produit très très premium sur
le domaine du projecteur alors là on est
toujours la maison plus particulier en
fait exactement en partie cuisine et le
produit un peu sympathique on lui
présente et c'est notre avenir figé
rateur must have you think you save your
parce qu'il ya toujours fait des grands
draps
les voitures
le réfrigérateur sérieux
et on peut voir qu'il ya à l'intérieur
du réfrigérateur sans avoir à ouvrir la
porte
je retombe dessus l'écran s'éteint
la particularité de ce réfrigérateur
c'est un réfrigérateur connectés
on est connecté à amazon alexa ça veut
dire qu'il ya plein de qualités
particulières j'ouvre un menu
vous avez la connectivité amazon avec ça
si vous activez le micro vous allez
pouvoir lui parler et lui demander des
choses deuxième fonctionnalité vous avez
une caméra embarquée dans le
réfrigérateur plus permis de regarder
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur du
réfrigérateur sans avoir à ouvrir la
porte
une autre fonctionnalité vous êtes
capable de dire aussi à votre
réfrigérateur ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
vous rentrez du beurre vous rentrez les
boissons vous rentrez des produits vous
les listes ee et le réfrigérateur va
être capable après de vous proposer des
recettes à partir des produits qui sont
disponibles dans votre réfrigérateur
d'accord une des recettes personnalisés
si la corse la pâtisserie ou les
produits que tu vas voir dans la maison
d'à côté
donc ça rien avant qu'un site des choses
oui ça y est en mesure de savoir d'un
feu d'origine mixte sauf si tu lui dis
sauf si tu lui dis j'ai ça et il peut
aussi le prendre en considération qu'on
compte proposer des recettes s'attaquant
même on retravaille 3 2
doran
ces données à l'intérieur oui mais au
service d'un peu plus d'un peu plus de
quelque chose de ludique et d'une valeur
ajoutée pour t'accompagner de mettre un
peu de fun de faire de la cuisine etc
c'est quand même un côté un peu
sympathique
et en termes de connectivité si je
choisis une recette par exemple celle là
il va me détailler la recette les
ingrédients qu'il faut faire mais il va
aussi nous proposer de préchauffer le
four est ici juste à côté bonsoir la
droite et il va lui parler
automatiquement et le fou en face au
très chaud fait à la bonne température
pour rôle la température nécessaire pour
cette recette ont connaissance et de la
connectivité entre les appareils lg dont
les cendres ont été effectivement
l'objet intelligent exactement aux côtés
sympathiques
vous pouvez gérer votre shopping list
liste de courses que vous allez pouvoir
ajouter au fur et à mesure et les
produits vont se commander sur amazon
alex sur amazon sur la mayenne
directement directement toutes les
livraisons et on s'est livré à la maison
domotique
quand on rentre les produits on peut
aussi rentrer une date d'expiration oui
c'est important pour les produits
seraient si jamais on arrive proche de
la date d'expiration au réfrigérateur va
envoyer une notification sur votre
smartphone ou sur son écran pour dire
attention il faut se dépêcher parce que
ce produit arrive
preuve que sa date d'expiration
de la connectivité sur internet regarder
sur l'écran
connecter à n'importe quel site au
hasard il va aller me chercher le site
correspondant je peux regarder
partager des choses la météo de la
journée est aussi accessible sur les
réfrigérateurs
fecteau beau à berlin le savent on est
pas mal vous prenez pas mal partagé des
photos depuis son smartphone entre la
famille
voilà ce qu'on pouvait avoir sur son
smartphone jeu
sur le réfrigérateur
et aussi les commandes basiques
de paramétrage du réfrigérateur et qu'on
peut contrôler la température et du
réfrigérateur et du fait du congélateur
directement sur les pour les enfants il
ya un côté aussi
très gaming vu qu'on peut mettre des
stickers ont peu joué et rajouter par
exemple un sticker
family envoi
un petit chien
je vais rester sur l'écran il est ici
jeudi
un petit mémo salue le matin avant de
partir et je peux le plat ses longs
cheveux derrière elle que même le
supprimer et à côté très ludique pour la
famille très sympa c'est le
réfrigérateur de demain il est déjà
commercialisé aux états unis pour
information il arrivera en france
prochainement pouvoir vous dire qu'en
encore mais c'est un point central de
l'as de la cuisine ouverte on a pas de
notion paris sur un produit comme ça va
encore et donc là continuent à la maison
puisqu'on partie blanc plus fait partie
blanc est là on vous parlait un peu plus
des lave-linge cette année sur de lave
linge on a une nouveauté on intègre une
solution d'intelligence artificielle
dans nos lave linge au service du soin
du linge généralement dans vos machines
à laver jusqu'à maintenant au démarrage
de votre site
le
j'ai posé mon retard quel est le poids
de votre linge pour savoir première dose
remettre après dans la machine à laver
et savoir quel cycle on va utiliser
dorénavant après cette première pesée
on va toujours injecter de l'eau mais le
lave-linge va effectuer une deuxième
plongée
pourquoi que le linge aura absorbé l'eau
vous savez pour textile en fonction de
leurs textures ont une capacité
d'absorption de l'eau qui est différente
de potence le synthétique 900 pallotta
même manière et donc à la fin ont un
emploi à différents os qu'une fois que
l'eau aura été absorbé lampard aux fins
et l'eau pour savoir quel textile est
majoritaire dans votre tombe aussi à
plus de synthétique ce qui est plutôt
content
et derrière avant de m'adapter les
mouvements du tambour la quantité d'eau
km dans le lave linge pour avoir une
meilleure performance de lavage et plus
en transition à deux voies destinées
l'intelligent qu on est sur une machine
à machins qui vont optimiser le soin de
votre linge surtout plus que plus que le
lavage votre votre texte il va durer
plus longtemps parce qu'on n'aura
adapter la manière de le traiter les
mouvements plus adaptée en fonction de
ces du coton du synthétique ou deux
techteam c'est là nous voyons un peu
pour ce tour de stand du côté de chez
jay a envoyé sa exhaustif l'idée c'est
deux fois la température en un instant t
de voir comment ça se passe on va parler
vachement de la maison connectée parce
qu'à beaucoup de choses dites à
l'intérêt s'employer beaucoup de techno
des choses qu'on va pas forcément
soupçonné donc c'est intéressant on en
parlera d'une moi si ça vous intéresse
pas ce que vous pensez que tout cet
écosystème lg ur lg encore me lançant le
smartphone pour l'instant c'est
on dirait un peu plus doucement mais on
en reparlera le carillon sur son jeu
fait des gros bisous je vous dis à
bientôt
geof